so last night last night was a night hey
President Trump has had himself quite a
week very big week for the President of
the United States and last night the
Democrats blew it in a massive massive
way they really did let me just explain
what the Democrats Week has gone like
because Trump is just the flip side of
that right if then I'm glad to have a
bad week that means that Trump had a
pretty good week so here is what the
Democrats have done over the last week
over the last week alone it's been a
crap week for them
I mean seriously so first there was the
Democrats bump in Iowa remember that was
gonna happen during a big publicity
Democrats bump in Iowa remember that
yeah then there was the Democrats
impeachment effort remember how that was
gonna go great for them they're gonna
impeach the President of the United
States remember that and who's gonna
give him a big bump because everyone was
gonna see how corrupt Trump was well
today they're taking that final
impeachment vote in the Senate the vote
to convict yeah yeah and then the
Democrats were making the case that
listen even if you like the economy even
if you like things that are going on in
foreign policy the President of the
United States is petty child.you petty
to radical child it's all chaos inside
the White House we are the adults in the
room right that's what we are worthy
adults in the room and you can trust us
with power because number one we know
how to handle things not like the Iowa
caucuses or anything and also we are not
going to be petty and mean-spirited and
ridiculous we're not going to act like
small children in any way so the
Democrats looking like adults right that
was going to be their their campaign was
that they were gonna restore honor and
dignity and decency to the White House
and then last night they just and you
know what all that adds up to you know
it all that adds up to the Democrats
2020 chances you know I've been fairly
bearish on the front chances for
re-election until 2020 right I said I'd
put them in no better than 5050 if
Donald Trump of last night shows up not
only is he gonna win he's gonna win big
now obviously we say this after every
Donald from State of the Union address
which is today is the moment Trump
finally arrived but the reality is that
Trump is at his strongest point of his
presidency he's at 49% in the Gallup
poll approval rating which is his
highest point of his presidency 63% of
Americans say that they
like the economy and they like how
president from handles the economy more
importantly and Democrats are looking
wilder more radical more ridiculous
more petty more thin-skinned more
childish every single day so you know
last night you know what it looked like
it looked like this is what they are
doing with their 20/20 chances the
Democrats 2020 chances this is a real
bad week for Democrats facts don't care
about your feelings and it's a fact that
the ben shapiro show is the largest
conservative podcast in the nation be
sure to hit the subscribe button to stay
up to date on all of our content